what's going on guys okay so today we
are doing the uh the live reaction to
two very important chapters the first
one is michael academia chapter
290 uh i'm sure most of you guys yeah we
all know what happens but uh this is the
official translation that's just come
out so we're going to go through that
like page by page
and then after that we're going to look
at black clover which is um i haven't
actually looked at the
i haven't really looked at the spoilers
for black clover so that's going to be
totally new just like everything's going
to be totally new basically
but my academia we're just looking at
the officials so uh yeah let's just get
into it
so um we kick off obviously on the first
page here so we see the hospital that
ray todoroki is being held in
and all of the doctors are seemingly
like rushing towards her room
uh super fast and the exact words are
kill the tv in room 315 she's been
making so much progress towards her
release
but now this talk about terrible timing
um so
naturally the doctors and everyone else
in japan are seeing that dabby is kind
of like uh
sent he's broadcasting his message to
all the tvs and computers in japan
and so they're just like yo we need to
kill the we need to kill everything
um so that reiterake does not see
anything else because naturally she's
still
you know in terms of her mental state
it's a bit fragile at the moment
although she's making progress this is
not a good thing for her right so
there's a bit of text and it's coming
from the tv
the live broadcaster on the news he's
kind of like a bit confused about what's
going on
and so this is the part where rey's eyes
just they're just like
what the hell is happening because she
thinks her son is dead and right here at
this panel right
right down here we can see darby and uh
yeah he's looking
pretty sad you know i mean this is a
serious moment right this is the thing
that
debbie has been building up towards
basically for the last 10 years
and now it's really happening so yeah
you can tell he's very serious possibly
the most serious
we've ever seen him um but before we get
into derby and everything about that
we get this awesome what is it it's kind
of like a
bird's eye view of giganto machia just
forging his way towards shigaraki
and we can see like this trail of
destruction he's just leaving behind him
it's
ridiculous so yeah all for one is like
superb timing from gigantomachia
because with maki as a rival it means
that sugaraki probably doesn't have to
fight too much anymore his body was
basically at its limit already
and as you can see here all for one goes
on to explain
tomorrow's body could fail at any moment
okay that's important
um and he goes on to say that he's
activated a few different quirks inside
sugaraki's body to reduce the bud and
place on his body and mind
so that's interesting right so all for
one is forcibly activating shigeraki's
own quirks
you know against shigaraki's will but is
to protect shigaraki obviously
but it's just interesting that all for
one can make shiguraki
you know use his use quirks against his
will basically um so that's quite
interesting
so moving on we see shoto by the way
should have just been amazing this whole
like these last few chapters
um so shoutout comes face to face with
sugaraki
he seems pretty fearless at this moment
i mean what are you thinking so he's
like
there's no way we can handle fighting
shigeraki and that giant
i better take shiguraki down since he's
already on his last legs
yeah so shoto is going in for the kill
he's going to destroy sugaraki
that's his intention anyway and we see
nejere swooping in so it's
nedurey and shoto versus shiguraki so
nedrae goes output level 100 so she uses
of her power and todoroki does the flash
fire fist
and both together they just destroy
shigaraki i mean
look look at that look at shigaraki's
face in here he's not having a good time
i mean
how many you know how many times a
shigiraki received a 100 attack from
someone
you know deku did 100 smashes endeavour
did his prominence burn which is his 100
nedra is doing her 100 todoroki is
giving his 100
like everyone is just giving their all
against shigaraki so he's not
having a good time right now but in this
little panel down here on the side
we can see uh endeavour just shouting
for everyone
just run just get out the way because we
know maki is coming right
so makia swoops in and we get this
awesome
awesome piece of art like this even if
you just forget the mag this is just an
amazing piece of art right here
um and macchia swoops in with his giant
claws
shigeraki is in one of his fingers he's
kind of like scooping shigaraki up
and in the meantime he's just destroying
everything else in his path
um and down in the corner we can see
deku is on the floor
um and bakago is being held by uh by
tenure
so makia talks to shigaraki and he's
basically saying your will is my command
so give me an order but as you can see
shigaraki is just he's he's
you know he's burnt out he's not talking
he's bit maybe he's even unconscious to
be honest
and uh what else do we see so endeavor
is now
pretty exhausted and he looks up and
he's thinking to himself
i'm sorry hawks it's my fault that this
giant is up and about
endeavour allowed sugar rocky to wake up
and so in his mind
by allowing shigaraki to wake up jaganta
maki has now come to shigaraki's aid
and uh and then this is the funny part
so we see debbie
um dabby emerges and he dab he's still
on dragon to make his shoulders
he kind of like emerges out of the
shadows and he's like oh hey you know
endeavor
um and he's shaking a bottle and i've
been reliably informed
uh on the in the youtube comments that
this bottle dab he has in his hand is
probably just water so um dabi's
basically he's happy to see endeavour he
knew endeavour would be there
but dabi didn't know that shoto would
also be there so it's just it's too
perfect it's too great
um so endeavour you know he said he's
like dabi damn it the league is here as
well
and dabi begins to pour the liquid over
his hair
and he says ouch like is that any way to
address me
and then next panel this is the moment
we've been waiting
hundreds of chapters for debbie says to
endeavor i have a great name
call me toya and we can just see
endeavors like
what the hell did you just say there's
even a little uh
speech bubble next to endeavour here
it's just blank so um dabi goes on to
say
you're really that dumb struck really
like
i know my face isn't what it used to be
but i was sure my own family would have
figured it out
i said it in a previous video but in dev
the one time endeavour came face to face
with darby in the manga
his vision was blurry right so it's you
can say that endeavor didn't get a good
look
but shoto on the other hand you know we
don't we don't know how close shoto was
to toya
but we do know that you know shoto saw
him close up
shot his vision was fine so it's a bit
surprising that he didn't
recognize him a little bit or suspect
anything but um
but yeah i guess the scarring is just
too much that they didn't even recognize
him
um so now we see deku and deku's like
wait what
uh because back during the endeavor
agency arc
deku remembered that um that shoto
mentioned his older brother toyah
even deku is realizing that this is
todoroki's brother
and so we move on back to the hospital
which is where we started the chapter
and we see debbie on the tv and he just
he straight up says it
i am toyotaroki the eldest son of
endeavor
to date i've killed over 30 innocent
people in cold blood
and today i'd like everyone to know
exactly what drove me
to do such despicable acts so debbie is
putting endeavour
on blast on national tv his goal right
now
is to destroy endeavour's hero career
and let everyone know that not only is
he
a terrible father but he also created
one of you know
one of japan's a serial killer basically
um dabi continues explaining his life
story
and he says once upon a time endeavour
yearned for nothing but power
but when he found himself unable to
surpass all might he despaired
to concoct even stronger quirks my
father forced the woman who would become
my mother
to marry him that's when my father
created me in pursuit of his selfish
egotistical dreams
but i was a failed creation it didn't
take long for him to reject me
i was tossed aside and forgotten but i
never forgot a thing
and i had plenty reason to keep watching
you and a quick little easter egg from
hirokoshi here
the little boy here and his shark friend
these are the two guys from the pro hero
arc
um this guy specifically he's one of
endeavour's biggest fans
and even he's watching this like what's
going on
and dabi says these murderous flames of
mine
are endeavour's flames and so we go back
to uh yeah we're on the battlefield
again
and so debbie says guess what my
pre-recorded life story is being
broadcast
nationwide and on the internet
and dabby starts to dance and he's like
i'm having a blast
uh and he's kind of like losing himself
he's like where was i again so daddy
goes on to say
how could i make you hurt i've been
pondering all that ever since that day
when you finally achieved your success
with your little puppet shoto
i thought killing him might do the trick
but then who would have guessed
you got bumped up to number one suddenly
i was rooting for your happiness
alright so just before we move on to the
next page it's interesting that debbie
says
he's been pondering endeavors you know
his downfall ever since
that day i'm assuming in the next
chapter we'll find out
what caused abby to to die and for toya
to um
to turn into what he is today um but we
still don't know what that day
what happened on that day you just yet
dabby goes on he says my blood ran cold
when i thought you might die
basically dab is referring to the fight
with the pro hero arc and against the
haya nomu
um and then he goes on to say that he
led different villains to fight endeavor
after this
so the first one he mentions is called
star servant
so star 7 was a villain that appeared at
the beginning of the endeavor agency arc
and he basically had the power to
manipulate glass but endeavour
and also hawks and and also the class 1a
students they dealt with they dealt with
star 7 pretty easily
um and then the other villain he refers
to is ending
and that villain actually uh captured
natsuo
so um it's interesting that debbie was
the one who sent ending because
ending threatened to kill you know
dabby's favorite sibling natsu
um so i wonder if the ending was going
off script when he captured him or if
that was always part of the plan
um but anyway debbie goes on to say you
were finally number one it's all you
ever wanted when at long last you could
stare your kids in the eyes
did you finally start to feel that warm
and fuzzy bonds
of family you must have thought as long
as i can face the future
i can be better um and so davidon i can
tell you at a loss for words
so here's the answer the past never dies
and uh this is just awesome like this
page right here
just the pose everything about this is
just so cool
um and so endeavour and shoutout they're
just like oh my god like
they're stressed out and dabby goes on
he says you reap what you sow so let's
tango
and dance with your son in hell and uh
the very last panel of this chapter we
see
the uh we see the the plane that has
best genus inside it
so best genus is still in the game he's
still plotting
and i guess in the next chapter best
genus will make it to the battlefield
and we'll see what he can do i assume
he's going to try and use his steel
fibers to tie up gigantomachia or
something
but as i've said previously best genus
cannot stop chagatomakia i don't think
so
if best genus was to stop gigantomachia
somehow
then in the next pro hero rankings if
there is a if there is a next pro hero
rankings
best units is definitely going to be
number one because endeavour's hero
career
as of this moment is over you know
nobody
how endeavors popularity after this
moment is going to be so far down
he might not even be in the top 10 if
he's still alive um and obviously we
know hawks his wings have burnt off so
he's kind of technically quirkless
so if best genius can do something
against machia then he's gonna be the
new number one hero
um which will be cool um but like i said
you know
hero society might not be so great after
this reveal from derby
but yeah guys that was everything from
my academia chapter 290
um so now i'm gonna read some of the
comments on uh on the twitch chat and
then we will go to the next page
sorry the next uh chapter for black
clover